好，來，咱繼續，咱繼續。仝款佇這本講義的第13頁，第13頁。
好，咱來看這个 n 喔，n，佇台語字是 n 喔，na，那，藍色的藍，抑是籃子的籃，n-a-na，第五調，第五調。
閣來 n-e-ne，ne，咱講呢啦，按呢、按呢，這个腔無仝。
閣來 ni，藍色的藍，ni，ni。閣這字，另外一个音叫做 ni，五點的點，五點的點。
好，閣來下跤，n-o-no，no，這个長老叫做 tióng-nóo，tióng-nóo，no。
閣來下跤，蛋，這个華語的蛋，讀做 nn̄g，第七調，nn̄g，第七調。所以伊的調有 w 的標佇 ng 的 n 頂面，ng 的 n 頂面。
好，閣來 l-a-la，la，這字 la。l-e-le，le，是第二調的 le，失禮的禮。
閣來 l-i-li，li，第二調，li，li，咱彼个啥物里，里民的里。閣來 l-oo-lôo，lôo，lôo，這个毋是姓，姓是 lû，lôo，lôo。
閣來囉唆的囉，口字旁，lô，口字旁閣一个囉，lô。閣來 l-o-lo，lo，lo，佮彼个滷肉的滷仝款，毋過字無仝，家己看，lo。
閣來 l-u-lû，仙女，嘛有人講仙女，腔無仝，仙女，仙女。閣來 k-a-ka，ka，加油的加，加油的加。
講著加油，咱華語所講去加油站加油，去加油站加油，咱台語欲按怎講？
加油、加油、加油，咱台語較正辦的叫做啥？添油。敢有聽過？我爸攏講，我來去添油，我來去加油站添油。
添，三點水閣一个真，添，華語的添，添油，添，用添的，油用添的。按呢咱台語講加油是啥？鼓勵加油，叫做加油。
咱會講，這擺考試愛加油喔，毋是叫你去加油站加油，是你愛加油。所以咱若講去加彼个燃料，咱會講添油，添油。
閣來下跤 ke，仝款，加減的加，咱會講 ke，所以加減咱唸做 ke-kiám。所以你看一字就兩个音，一个唸做 ka，一个唸做 ke。
加講的，加講。以前咱上班的時，啊你加講的，加講，多講的，加講。閣來 k-i-ki，這个基，基本的基，開基，開基，咱台灣真濟，台南遐，古城真濟開基，開基祖啦，怹彼个廟寺的廟，開基廟，基。
閣來 k-oo-kô，kô，啥物 kô，啥物按，啥物 kô 啥物 kô 的 kô。閣來 k-o-ko，這攏知，阿姑的姑，阿姑、香菇、冬菇嘛是，香菇的姑。
咱台語有一个，教你無心，做這个欲食菇，香菇的姑，欲食菇，意思就是講無意義。閣來 k-u-ku，ku。
所以咱華語講烏龜，咱台語講一字就好，龜。咱華語的烏龜就台語的龜。你毋通兩字照唸，你若兩字照唸叫做烏龜，烏龜的烏，烏龜，烏龜就是彼个拉皮條的，烏龜。
閣來 k-ng-kng，kng，光明的光，kng，kng，k-ng，唸做 ng 喔，k-ng-kng，kng，光，光明的光。彼个摃，提手旁閣一个工，嘛是唸做 kòng，kòng-kiû 的 kòng。
閣來 kh-a-kha，這个第二調，kha，食巧毋食飽，食巧毋食飽，kh-a-kha。這字巧，閣有另外一个同音，叫做 khiáu，聰明就是這字，叫做 khiáu，就是這字巧。
閣來 kh-e-khe，第一調 khe，這攏知。所以咱講，攏是別人的錯，嫌東嫌西，袂曉駛船嫌溪彎。
袂曉駛船嫌溪彎。閣來 kh-i-khì，欺騙的欺，起，早起的起。kh-oo-khô，這逐家攏知，苦，哪一苦。閣來 kh-o-khó，khó，第二調 khó，khó。
救苦的苦。閣來 kh-u-khu，這攏知，第一調 khu。閣來下跤，米糠的糠，kh-ng-khng，khng，米糠的糠。
閣來後壁，g，濁音，g-a-gâ，第五調 gâ，gâ。gâ 是啥你知無？螺絲，螺絲彼个紋，螺絲鉸，螺絲鉸。
怹烏手攏講，彼个螺紋若磨損的，就 bak-gâ，螺絲 bak-gâ。bak-gâ 是日語。怹烏手界真濟攏用這字，用這字。所以咱用台羅拼音才有法度拼出彼个音，漢字毋一定寫有。
親像講彼个螺絲起子，怹攏用台羅，攏用台羅拼音，怹有一寡家私攏用這字。閣來第二組，g-e-gê，gê，gê，第七調 gê，gê-sut 的 gê。
你若唸做 gê-sut 就變做第三調，gê，gê。閣來 g-i-gî，gî，gî，所以宜蘭咱唸做 Gî-lân，Gî-lân。所以華語真濟義、宜，會唸做 g-i-gî，Gî-lân，攏唸 Gî-lân。
閣來 g-oo-gô，gô，海跤，咱中部海跤怹會唸做啥？giâ。我以前同事，怹兜蹛佇彼个梧棲彼爿，我欲去怹兜，伊老母講，你欲食 giâ 某？
聽無，我聽無。原來怹彼个鵝肉，鵝肉。我才知影怹彼爿鵝講 giâ，giâ-bah。閣來，g-o-gô，gô，gô，第七調 gô，gô-pê-gô。
閣來 g-u-gû，這攏知，第五調 gû。閣來 third 種濁音，ng，ng，ng-a-ngá，雅，優雅的雅，ngá-ngá。咱台中北爿彼个叫做大雅。
伊變做 n-g-e-2，第二調，ngé。閣來 ng-e，ngē，ngē，伊是第七調，ngē。ngē 是啥？困難的、毋好做的叫做 ngē。
你攏揀軟的，我攏食硬的。你專揀軟柿子，毋好的、困難的就留予我. 我攏食硬的，你攏食軟的。所以軟的就寫做軟。
這攏咱台語的一種藝術，咱台語真有藝術，軟的、硬的。你若華語人就聽無，這是啥？會使食無？伊是在講形容代誌。
你攏揀軟的，我攏食硬的。閣來下跤，ng-i-ngî，仝款，伊是無仝腔口，咱講 ngē 講 ngî，ngî。下跤這个我，ng-oo-ngóo，ngóo。
〔此段辨識失敗〕
好，啊
閣來，啊
中，資、庸、中，中、中、中
彼個宋中的中，中
吃
咱逐工逐日攏咧食的，吃啊，吃
吃、昂、倉，倉仔的倉，倉，好
吃、英、清，清，好
所以，咱講食的清淡
咱台語真少講淡
講食真清，食真清
就是食的清淡
好，閣來，吃、翁、蔥，聰明的聰，好
吃、一、昂、強，第四聲喔
吃、一、昂、強，強
沖水，強水
咱講，啊，去，去便所愛去強水，好
這字強，咱台語有一個咱較捷聽到的
瀑布，瀑布
水強
所以強水佮倒轉，叫做水強
水強，瀑布啦
水強
水強，強水，毋是強水
因為彼個水的力道真大，所以用強
我徛佇水強的下跤，強水
水強，強水，強水是動詞，水強是名詞，瀑布
好，下跤閣一個 I-O-N-G 喔
吃、用、衝，衝，也是這字衝
是啥？露衝的衝
看風水的露衝，這字衝，中中的中
露衝的衝
閣彼個衝突的衝，也是仝音
衝撞的衝，也是仝音
有的彼個手字衝，衝、衝、衝、衝
所以這字衝，行中間加一個虫
這字衝，咱若講闖紅燈，咱會講衝紅燈
你毋通去弄紅燈，弄的彼字人字邊閣一個弄
毋通去弄紅燈，衝的，好
閣來，思，思、安、三，輕鬆的三，好
思、英、生，人生的生，思、翁、爽，爽，真爽的爽，好
思、一、昂、箱，彼個箱，一箱兩箱的箱
閣來，思、一、用、傷，傷
受傷的傷，閣有
很嚴重
這次車禍呢，他受傷得很嚴重
傷重，傷重
傷重
這改車禍，受傷甲真傷重
受傷，受傷，咱華語講受傷，咱講受傷
受傷，受傷，咱這馬攏講受傷、受傷，其實台語是講受傷
受傷，受傷
彼個傷，傷，閣有一個叫做傷
傷，傷
所以這字，這字傷重，就是很嚴重，好，咱唸閣一個音
思、一、用、傷
太重，傷重，仝字，無仝音，無仝意思
這物件傷重，我搬袂起
我無愛，傷重，同樣是這字傷，唸做傷
所以咱台文上無這字攏兩個音
你看，重、重，傷重、傷重
我兩手搬一個傷重，受傷甲真傷重
所以你可以共這台文開始造句
你去想看覓伊欲按怎發音，你就知伊的意思，你就可以自我造句
好，咱看下跤這日，日
日來加 I-A-N-G 呢，日、一、昂、樣，樣
樣
應用樣的樣，這字樣有人嘛唸做樣
樣、樣
這字日，講到這字日，咱佇，我台中人，正港台中人
日，這字日，有時陣攏會音變，變做 G，G，G，G
應用樣，樣，阮攏會講做樣
樣、樣，變做 G，G，台中一寡音
攏按呢，親像講彼個棒球
伊的聲母是日，日、一、歐、饒、饒，伊是第七聲
阮台中若講棒球，攏會聽伊講棒球
伊的聲母變成 G
台中人，閣有這腔，這聲母這款腔佇南投嘛聽得到
南投我嘛佇埔里聽過
咱台中佮南投的伊的這聲母有的無精差
日，有的日，伊攏會唸聲母的日，攏唸做 G，G
樣、樣，應用樣
按呢講應用樣，其實伊到底是啥？樣，閣有樣，閣來，茸，茸仔豹的茸，茸
日、一、翁、茸、茸，第八聲喔，茸
咱過彼個母親節，彼個
代表母親節的彼個花，咱講千日紅花
千日紅花，千，千日紅花
千日紅花，千
伊加出來的花，按呢茸仔豹按呢，千日紅花
好，後壁這第十九頁遮，入聲，入聲有過，看過
好，入聲有過，咱嘛是入聲佮這 NG 這，我覺得較重要，伊的發音，伊的發音的時，好
咱來看十九頁遮，入聲母的，閣 AP，AP 唸做 ap
一盒兩盒的盒，閣來，AT，at，at，這 at，at 轉的 at，閣有彼個 at
at，閣來 AK，ak，ak 龜的 ak
AH，ah，牛母魚的 ah，閣來，ip，這 ip 是啥？提手旁閣一個意，彼個揖網仔
飛龍的是，揖網仔，彼個網仔咱佇，佇彼個
後壁塗豆底嘛，伊面頂，伊底彼個
一張一張，叫做揖網仔
揖網，閣有嘛講彼個過網仔，嘛講底網仔
一張一張，按呢底佇遐，好
嘛講過網仔
嘿，對對對，攏有，好，閣來 it，一二三四的 it，閣來 ik，這利益的益，好
IH 無，閣來 UT，ut，熨斗的 ut
好，下跤咱來看一個有聲母的
PAP 無，PAT，pat，有 pat，伊是第八聲喔，PAT，pat，pat
咱攏無第八聲，咱攏唸做 pat，其實伊本調叫做 pat
一二三四五六七八，pat，pat，彼個 pat-ti̍t
pat-ti̍t 有在，pat-ti̍t 有在，嘛有人按呢講，按呢講三八三八按呢，pat-ti̍t
pat-ti̍t，閣來這 pak，pak，彼個剝削的削，剝啦，pak
剝皮 pak，這字另外一個叫做 pe̍h，pe̍h-puê，彼是白話音，剝皮愛 pe̍h-puê，這字是 pak，pak-siat
剝削的削，pak-siat，閣來一百兩百的 pah，pah，pah
閣彼個大 pah 的 pah，大 pah，大鈔
咱講大鈔咱講大 pah，大 pah，啊若零錢，咱講零星，零星，零零星星的零星，零星
零星，零星
所以有時你共伊讀看覓，彼個用華語唸佮用台語唸，意思真正有當時仔彼個意思感覺
感覺較老，你講彼個人壽公司，南山，南山人壽南山的，閣有一本
人生
南山，就是一些零錢啦，零錢，嘿，有一本雜誌有一本雜誌
華語唸，很
正常，實力對吧？
咱台語就足快意欸喔
這本十全食美
就是很嚴重，食力
食力，咱朋友嘛食力，食力
其實伊欲唸普通音嘛，叫做食力，食力
閣來閣看，這个筆，鉛筆的筆，這攏知，筆
閣來，逼，逼迫的逼，逼
閣來，鼻，鼻，鼻，鼻涕的鼻，鼻
鼻有一个形容詞叫做鼻鼻
不乾脆，做代誌鼻鼻仔
閣來，不，不定義的不，意思不原因嘛，不，不定義的不
ph，ph，這个覆，覆蓋的覆，ph，覆
這个覆是啥？覆載的覆，覆載的覆就是這个，覆蓋的覆這个覆，覆載
覆載攏嘛聽過
閣來，ph-a-pha，頭先講的，拍字的拍，拍字的拍
閣下，鼻，鼻，鼻涕的鼻，鼻
閣來，ph-e-phe，撇，撇，文言文嘛是這个撇，撇
閣來，ph-i-phi，譬，譬相，譬相就是譏笑，閣兼彼个揶揄啦
譬相足歹聽的，譬
閣下這个捔，捔就是拿刀揮，用揮動的去砍，叫做捔
捔草啦，抑是講這个捔柴火啦，捔，動作比較快，力道比較大，捔
m，m-a-h，嘛，嘛，嘛
這个喔，是囥佇語尾，你嘛共我講一个嘛，嘛
閣下這个物，物，這个食物，好食物，好吃的東西，食物，食物，咱嘛講食物，嘛講食物，物
閣來，b-a-t，密
這个是啥？密密
這个密，密密，密
這个密，密密
閣來，木，b-a-k，木，這个做木，就是木工、木匠，木
閣來，肉，肉，這攏知
味，芳味的味，味
閣來，妙，妙，這个是彼个幽默，咱嘛叫做幽妙，幽妙
閣下，避，寫做避見，就是躲起來的意思
避見，毋予人看著避見，叫做避，避相揣，避相揣，捉迷藏，避相揣
揣是提手旁，揣
揣，揣，避，躲起來
閣來，t，t-a-p，答，回答的答
t-a-t，踏，踏
有人名啦，閣彼个踏到，你若欲講踏到，踏到，踏到地，踏
閣來，塔，這个塔就是塔婆，塔婆的塔，塔
t-a-h，t-a-h，塔，塔，塔，塔
這个唸做塔，塔，塔
閣下，直直的直，直，直，直直的直
閣來，敵人的敵，敵，敵，無敵的敵
t-i-h，值，值
閣來，t-u-t，突，突
有一个唐突，唐突的突
th，t-h-a-p，t-h-a-p，塔，塔，填空叫做塔空
塔空，填空，親像講咱彼个考卷，填空，會寫做塔空
塔空，填空
這个塔，凹落去的凹，叫做塔，親像講彼个面箍，塔塔，眼眶凹陷，塔塔
閣下，t-h-a-t，踏，這个踏攏知，用跤踏
閣下，t-h-a-k，t-h-a-k，讀冊的讀，所以讀書，咱會用做毋是用書，用冊，冊子的冊，讀冊
閣來，塔，這个塔攏知，水塔的塔
閣下這个
t-h-i，t-h-i，剔，剔頭的剔，日字旁的一个剔，月，月閣一个剔部，叫做剔頭
剔頭就兩个意思，一个是玩耍，一个是在江湖上跟人家混
閣下，t-h-e-k，剔，所以排斥的咱講排剔，排剔，排列的排，排斥一樣，寫做彼个剔，排剔
閣來，剔，這个剔攏知
閣來，t-h-u-t，u-t唸做ut，t-h-ut，thut，thut-thâu，thut-thâu，禿頭
閣下，後壁，n，n-a，那，那，閃那，閃那是什麼？閃電，華語的閃電，閃那的那，寫做這个那
閣彼个，那日
那日是啥？那日就是親像咱這馬開始入秋，彼个日頭，無出來的時間越來越短
那日就是太陽出來一下下，叫做那日
閣下，n-i-h，呢，呢跤尾的呢，墊腳尖，墊腳尖，叫做呢跤尾的呢，這个呢
閣竹字旁改成木字旁，仝款嘛是唸做呢，就是眨眼的眨，眨眼睛
呢，目一个呢，就是伊的部首，伊的這个字邊改成目
l，l-a-p，納，納稅金的納
閣下，l-a-t，力，力，伊是第八調，力，力草的力，力草就是力量、力道
l-a-k，六，嘛是仝款第八調，六，這个三四五六的六，咱攏無第八調，咱攏唸做五六，伊是第八調，六
閣來，喇叭的喇，喇，l-a-h，喇
閣來，立正的立，l-i-p，l-ip，立
閣來，暱稱的暱，暱，i-t唸做it嘛，l-it，暱，暱
閣下，力量的力，l-ek，伊是第八調，力，力
所以一个字就有兩个音，力嘛一個叫做la̍t，一个叫做li̍k
閣來，l-i-h，i-h唸做i，l-i，裂，這个是動詞，也是單位，單位量詞，裂，一裂，伊是第八調，裂，一裂
抑是寫做裂開的裂，一裂，後壁彼个一裂，伊是單位詞，頭前是動詞，裂開的裂，就裂開一个縫，一裂
親像講，我的衫，欲，欲，欲崩，抑是裂一裂
彼个褲跤，褲，褲，彼个尻川斗裂一裂，就是裂開，裂開一个縫
閣來，律師的律，u-t，ut，l-ut，lut，律師的律
閣來，k-a，a-p，k-a-p，k-ap，蛤
這个蛤仔，這是蛤仔，蛤仔是啥？青蛙
毋通予華文誤導囉，這蛤，蛤仔是青蛙，閣叫做四跤仔
你有聽過蛤仔無？蛤仔，毋過伊咧講無講，蛤仔就是青蛙，蛤仔、四跤仔攏叫做青蛙
Frog，這个字是青蛙的意思
我頭先強調講毋通予華文，毋通予華文誤導囉，伊欲講蛤仔對無？
蛤仔的蛤
好，謝謝，好吧
蛤蜊，蛤蜊，我佇彼個，佇喙練習看一幅像
一台貨車，怹咧，怹咧拍，做蛤蜊的，蛤蜊的廣告
伊的車頂面寫，掌聲蛤蜊蛤蜊
愛包含喔，掌聲鼓勵鼓勵寫掌聲蛤蜊蛤蜊
蛤蜊就是這，蛤蜊，好，蛤蜊
啊，跤步是水雞，跤步是水雞
所以不要看到他這個，喔，你就這蛤蜊，毋是喔，蛤蜊是按呢寫
這字蛤，閣有啥？肉蛤，眼眶，肉蛤
好，這字蛤，好
好，落跤 KAT，KAT，割，啊，割
頭先講過喔，拍死割的割，閣來 KAK，角，啊，角
角，彼個，頭先有拍過嘛，閣有一個八角喔，彼嘛是有肉的，有肉的滷味，八角
閣來 KAH，甲，啊，甲，甲，這字呢，有幾个意思
一个是，咱一般知，布袋，面，一个單位，一角兩角的角
好，閣來，第二個，程度，程度副詞
咱講到彼工，講，到，它是一個華語的到的意思
閣有，咱講這个物件，欲，好食甲，就，好食甲
好食到難以形容，好食甲，按呢，就好食甲，到遮爾，咱台語的到遮爾
就是講，那個，那個程度你自己去體會，按呢講好食甲
頭前，頭前講，好食甲啦，跳甲，喔，彼有一條歌嘛，跳甲，爽甲，就是這字甲
程度副詞，就是這字甲喔，伊這字是，好食甲，它是雙連音，所以兩字連寫好食甲
伊本調是甲，好，閣來 KIP，急，喔，急，急的急，這喙唇愛合喔
啊 P，閣來，喙唇愛合，急，好，閣來，急促的急，IG 唸做 IK，閣，伊，急，急促
好，彼个急促，急促攏佇宜蘭較濟人，閣來 IK 唸做 IK，閣，伊，極
好，革命，革命的極，好，閣來 IH，伊，閣，伊，極
極，極，極，一九，閣，伊，極，極，IH 嘛，伊，伊，伊毋是 IK 喔，是 IH，閣，伊，極
七，這字較罕得看著喔，好，閣來 UT，溫，閣，溫，棍，棍，棍頭的棍
好，閣來，KH，科，科，啊，磕，磕頭，閣有啥？磕袂著，磕袂著
動不動就怎麼樣，磕袂著，這字磕，磕袂著，動不動
磕袂著欲按怎按怎按怎，磕袂著四界走，好，落跤 AT，AT，科，啊，磕
動詞，咬，咬啦，華語的咬，好，名詞，跤落，勺子，較大的，湯勺仔的跤落
啊古早人攏用彼个瓢喔，瓢跤落，瓢跤落，好，這字跤，舌頭的跤，好，跤頭的跤
好，閣來 KHAK，AK，啊，科，啊，磕，帶殼，磕，什麼磕，後壁 T 磕，啥物蝦磕的磕
好，閣來 AH，啊，科，啊，較，這个就是，較按怎，較，我較愛食啥，比較，比較怎麼樣
好，KIP 唸做 IP，科，伊，潗，頭先講過潗，潗水管的潗，潗水管的潗
好，閣來 IT，IT，科，伊，乞，乞食的乞，乞食的乞，乞食的華語寫成乞丐
咱愛寫佗一字？乞食，乞士喔，這个乞食，乞食
所以呢，咱有時寫講去食去食，咱講乞食乞食，你共我罵，喔，乞食
好，閣來 IK，IK 唸做 IK，科，伊，隙，隙縫的隙
好，IH，伊，科，伊，缺，缺角，缺，咱講碗，碗有缺角喔，缺角，角它是寫成縫隙的隙
這个碗缺角，咱唸第二聲，第三聲缺角，缺，這字是缺
就缺一个角，缺角，KHIH，缺角，碗缺一角喔，它也是單位詞，角
好，閣來 UT，溫，KH，科，溫，睏，睏去，睏去，睏
好，知影，好，中場休息